the legal battle between johnny depp and
his ex-wife isn't going away anytime
soon amber hurt planning to appeal the
blockbuster verdict that found her
liable for defaming depp who is seen
here living it up in britain while
mingling with his adoring fans
amber's attorney revealing the actress
won't be able to pony up and is
complaining about the process
are you stunned that the jury
essentially rejected her story a number
of things were allowed in this court
that should not have been allowed and it
caused the jury to be confused does your
client want to appeal
oh absolutely and she has some excellent
grounds for it is she able to pay a 10.4
million dollar judgment oh no absolutely
not all right judge
what happens now
okay so the attorney says that she's
going to appeal uh i don't know what
she's going to appeal about this
attorney is talking about the fact that
there was evidence admitted that
shouldn't have been admitted
let's make sure let's hope she made a
record for appeal but one of the things
she's complaining about is the social
media and how that influenced the jury
well every jury is informed that they
cannot consider
newspapers or what people say or social
media in determining what what their
verdict is going to be i suspected
she'll appeal i don't know if she has
the money to appeal but at the same time
if she doesn't have the money any future
wages she gets will be garnished there's
a judgment against her it's a legitimate
judgment if there is an appeal it
doesn't mean anything it doesn't
necessarily mean if she wins that
there'll be a new trial i think the
evidence was overwhelming on the part of
johnny depp the plaintiff in this case
she was overwhelmingly seen as a liar
and not a credible witness and in the
end i think that uh you know it's kind
of interesting that she says they don't
have money when she just bought a house
she just insisted on living in three
penthouses she and her girlfriends that
johnny depp owns
she was a she was a taker and we'll see
what happens but what she did the one
thing that she did was she hurt battered
women she hurt the women coming forward
and you know she talks about how you
know that she felt the wrath of society
no you created a wrath that wasn't there
because you tried to ride on the uh on
the wings of battered women ride on the
wings of battered women
jessica
good point where did the money go didn't
johnny just give her millions and
millions of dollars when they got
divorced well people who live these
kinds of lifestyles can blow through
money very quickly and they also have a
very warp sense of what their standard
of living should be this happens all the
time in divorce cases where you hear
whoever is asking for alimony says well
yeah i obviously need 60 grand a month
because these are the things that i do
and it's like well you don't do the job
that does the thing
so
i just to piggyback on the judge's point
about what this what happened about our
women i was reading a lot of coverage of
this last night from you know left-wing
and right-wing sources and this was a
concern for every single person that was
writing about the issue whether they
actually believed amber heard or not and
they just said that that this put the
idea of calling into question or that
people fake these kinds of things so
blatantly all over our televisions that
it's going to have a really negative
effect long term on true survivors of
domestic violence who have a right to
take people to court over things like
this
do you think gianni will garnish her
wages or do you think there will not be
any wages to garnish i don't know
what the garnishing will look like
i'm not sure but i was thinking about
the lead up to this and whether she's
thinking it was worth it like a
publicist tried to get her on the me too
train on the time's up pr agency that
hollywood put together during the metoo
movement they were they turned it into
this whole red carpet event everybody
was getting in on it always aclu pushed
the pusher into the washington post
thought this isn't her fault but pushed
her into the washington post op-ed which
they now put you know an editor's note
on so you know this was
a matter of jumping on the bandwagon for
attention and it didn't end up very
going very well for her greg you know uh
you bring up the washington post and
that to me would be the ideal next step
is that depp should sue the washington
post i mean i'm glad that he got his day
in court but it you know not everyone
has you know depth pockets oh thank you
um i wonder how many pieces have been
run in the washington post that were
just as falsely malicious but no one had
the power or the finances to fight them
so he has the power to put up his dukes
and you gotta wonder you know how much
of input did the washington post have uh
she you know it's clear she didn't write
the piece allegedly she didn't write it
aclu claimed that somebody had played
together but you know i'm sure the
washington post was happy to get it
maybe they helped her why didn't they
name that because they knew they didn't
have to it was going to be obvious so
there seems it seems to me there's
they're getting away with it and they
got
deeper pockets than amber heard so i
would it would be really nice to see you
see a nick sandman type move you know
and then depp can play nick sandman in
the nick sandman movie
once i get
depth pockets i'm going to sue the
washington post i'm going to sue you
you can't sue me yeah i can't no you
can't oh i've got pictures oh those were
private greg
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else